grab a Fanta and snort the devil's dust
because it's episode 8 of American
Horror Story apocalypse and this one has
an angel in a diaper
Michael is back from his walk in the
wilderness only to uncover the
extra-crispy corpses of ariel baldwin
and mama satan extra-crispy and this is
just you know but Michael seems to know
that's the charred remains of his mom
experienced a flashback of her with that
creepy smile as she's being burned he
lets out a Satan scream before being
confronted by Cordelia who tells him
it's all over all his allies are dead he
defiantly tells her that he'll just
bring her back from the depths of hell
but Cordelia is one step ahead having
placed a spell on her soul that only she
can break this explains why I mean was a
robot in the first few episodes since
Michael couldn't bring her back he had
to do the next best thing
reconstruct her from scratch we'll get
to that near the end of the episode she
tries to tell him he doesn't have to
follow his father Satan he can make his
own destiny but my guess is that he's
not going to be too receptive to the
woman who just killed the most important
person in his life she asks him to come
with her to find his humanity taking her
hand he brings her in close pledging
he'll bring me back and kill every last
witch now I'm not sure why Cordelia
doesn't just kill him right here but hey
what do I know maybe she isn't powerful
enough seeing how her powers are waning
with no one left but his father down
below Michael creates a pentagram in the
forest asking him what to do whereas in
the beginning he was scared of his
powers he's now embraced them ready to
go full evil ready to die for his father
he just needs guidance as if things
couldn't get any worse after four days
alone he's offered a grape Fanta by a
spooky forest child he hallucinates
visions of grape Fanta and his mother
haunting him that's before he's told by
Anton LaVey he's perfect seething with
rage Michael attacks but Anton turns
into an angel who then disappears
replaced by a goat who he brutally
mutilates and snakes come out of it and
that is why we don't drink Fanta
frustrated and alone Michael enters a
run-down building with an upside-down
cross we've seen this symbol before and
mama Meade's car before she picks up the
sacrificial woman inside the
congregation is berated by its leader
Hannah
they've been slacking on
King sins and if they're gonna pave the
way for their arrival of the Antichrist
they gotta pick it up she tells them to
go out and inspire her as an offering
plate is passed around
Michael meets Madeline who offers to
make him something to eat for days in
the wilderness with nothing but Fanta
can really take a toll on you
she's seen kids like him before seduced
by the free donuts at check-in
Michael tells his story about how his
father abandoned him in this particular
instance he's referring to Ben Harmon
who for a brief time became his father
then abandoned him then telling her his
mother tried to kill him this time
referring to Vivien Harmon who as a
ghost tried to kill him
humanity is [ __ ] and no wonder Michael
holds a grudge against it she sees in
Michael the future of Satanism they need
people like him to spread the word of
Lucifer because once you realize were
all degenerate rotten people you become
free Satanism is about giving in to your
urges embracing sin and your true nature
we learned Madeline sold her soul to the
devil and in return got a lazy boy in
premium cable let's not forget Brad Pitt
and Ryan Reynolds but Satanism is much
more than just carnal pleasure they have
to prepare for their Savior the spawn of
Satan if things are terrible enough on
earth he can finally rise but Michael is
disillusioned with her talk telling her
she's waiting in vain and when he tells
her he's the one she's waiting for she
puts a knife to his throat and threatens
to kill him for being a blasphemer it's
only when he reveals the 666 mark of the
beast
does she bow down to him and hail Satan
and then were treated to the best church
choir I've ever heard performing Carl
Orff's Carmina Burana a piece written as
a complaint against a Fortuna the
inexorable fate that rules both God's
and mortals in Roman and Greek mythology
some of the translations here include
how fate crushes the brave and all will
soon weep Michael is rushed to the
church for Hannah's undergoing a good
old-fashioned human sacrifice the
victims of which are people who have
done nothing but good in their lives
those are the sacrifices Satan loves the
most the honor of today's sacrifice goes
to Phil who was a former employee of
Gawker if you remember Gawker was put
out of business when they decided to
release Hulk Hogan's sex tape and was
fined a hundred and forty billion
dollars Fox afford
about what we're going from here Phil is
ready to pledge his soul to Satan about
to kill when Madeline interrupts seeing
the honor should go to Michael he
reveals the mark to Hanna proclaiming
that he is indeed the one and they all
bow in reverence he's given the knife to
finish the deed and in one fell swoop
cuts both their throats as the
congregation cheers Michael is finally
beginning to find his place at the
church Michael is given a meal fit for
the spawn of Satan macaroni salad and
turkey meatballs
Madeline shoes the others away and says
it would be an honor watching him eat
she asked him what's next but he's not
sure being the spawn of Satan didn't
exactly come with an instruction manual
she gives him a pep talk saying there
must be a way to get me back on their
way down the coast Madeline tells him
about a secret network of people who
have sold their souls wherever they're
going it seems some powerful people or
person is at the top as she drops him
off she has a heartwarming farewell in
which he asked to burn for eternity in
service she mentions wanting to be
stationed in the lowest circle of Hell
which is a reference to Dante's Inferno
in which the poet describes Hell being
structured into nine circles Billy
Eichner who by the way is listed as
being called mutt and Evan Peters listed
as Jeff snort some cocaine and Dawn
their best Planet of the Apes haircuts
when we see their robot engineers
engineers for robots which serve a hmm
specific kind of purpose then it goes
hardcore mode or as I like to call it a
Friday night and the boys try to get to
the bottom of it Billy calls for holy
crap miss Venable I enjoy how the season
is starting to put all the parts
together and I don't mean the robotic
ones she still has that steely don't
[ __ ] with me glare I am a [ __ ] Venable
interrupts the two gentlemen with the
most obnoxious bowl of cocaine known to
man they gush how they wouldn't survive
without her I mean she did send a pile
of [ __ ] to Mark Zuckerberg she tells
them Michael arrives and chastises them
don't ever call me [ __ ]
and then there's more cocaine Jeff and
mutt welcome Michael proclaiming that
they thought he looked more like the raw
I mean it almost becomes like a roast
for them how are they supposed to know
he's the Antichrist he then shows his
mark but goes one step further lighting
in flames [ __ ] lady extra crispy
appease that he is the real deal they
enjoy a nice sushi meal why work as a
slave when you can have everything you
want as long as you sell your soul to
the devil they pledged their servitude
to Michael wishing the fiery end of
Earth asking what they can do to make it
happen Michael passes them a photo of
Meade wanting them to bring her back he
came to the right place Jeff and mut get
hard to work only perfection is deserved
for the spawn of Satan so what do they
do
make her Mossad if you remember earlier
in the season the memory of young need
as a Mossad agent on Halloween disposing
of a bad guy that was all implanted by
these two coked up fiends Michael is
amazed by their work they tell him not
to mention to her that she's a robot it
could send her in an existential crisis
hence why Meade didn't know she was a
robot until she was shot in the bunker
she awakens and instantly remembers him
now that they're together he can begin
his revenge against the witches but how
exactly does Meade wind up in that
bunker with them was it all a plan to
keep tabs on the witches he knew we're
going to be there we'll just have to
keep staying tuned to find out thanks
for giving this video watch as always
please give the video a like and if you
haven't subscribed yet what are you
waiting for you dummy I'll be back next
week for episode 9 and more videos in
between so stay tuned and don't you
forget daddy loves you very much